Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me. You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, good morning. My name's Phil Sli.
I'm the pastor of discipleship and community here at Henderson Hills Baptist
Church. And I want to thank Pastor John and our elder council for giving me the
opportunity to preach God's word and to proclaim the gospel of Jesus Christ.
It's good to be here today.
And I also wanna say for a moment that my good friend David Amon has, um,
driven up here from Tulsa, Oklahoma to see me preach.
And what I was thinking today is I was walking into the building, as you know,
I met David Amon about 55 years ago at vacation Bible school. And,
uh, we were discipled together and we grew up loving the Lord together.
And so he's here to support me this morning. So, uh,
if you have your Bibles turn to Psalm 56. While you're turning there,
I wanna give a little backstory.
We know that sin separated humanity from God and,
and God immediately made a promise to the serpent, the personification of evil.
And he said, the offspring of a woman will crush your head.
So that's the first gospel proclamation.
That's the first gospel prophecy that it would one day result in the coming
of a deliverer to give us hope.
And you and I know that this prophecy finds its fulfillment in Jesus through
his death and burial and resurrection.
He is the deliverer and that's the gospel.
Jesus tri triumphed over Satan through his death barrel and resurrection.
So that's the good news and that's the gospel later. And that happened in, uh,
Genesis three. Later in Genesis 12,
God makes another promise and he promises Abram, he says,
and now Abraham's an old man with a barren wife, and he says,
you're going to have a son. And uh,
that son is going to be the beginning of a great nation.
And so God keeps his promises. And that's exactly what happened,
that God's offspring would bless all the nations of the earth and that
eventually ended up in Jesus. But, but God's people,
this little family,
God guided them and protected them and then warned them as they began to grow,
not to put anything else first.
And if they did that there would be consequences.
And so he promised them a land and he gave them a land and he promised them a
temple and he gave them a temple.
But any way they did what they did, they turned away from God,
even against the warnings,
and they ignored his prophets and they begin to make other gods
and worship other gods. And so consequently,
God allowed his temple to be destroyed and for his people to be exiled away
from the land and away from the temple for 370 years,
that is where they had worshiped God as he promised that they would.
But because of their rebellion,
God's people were exiled away from the land and the temple and the Psalms as
we read them,
this was how God's people worshiped him away from their home,
away from their temple. So in this Psalm 56, it says,
it's to the choir master.
And so it was sung by Abraham's offspring,
God's people in exile. And so the Psalms helped them draw,
draw close to God even when they were far away from home.
The Psalms became like a hymnal or a prayer book,
poems for exiled Israelis. The word psalm is a Greek word.
It means the plucking of the strings. And so, uh, God's people sung these poems,
sung these songs as they were accompanied by string instruments.
And I didn't know this,
but the Psalms are the world's largest collection of ancient poetry.
And they transcend time and they point us to God. They reveal God,
how he is long suffering, how he inspires us, how he's powerful,
how he's holy, how he's merciful, how he's God, and how he's love,
and because of his love, how he's with us in suffering.
So why do we study the Psalms? They help us understand,
they help us understand God,
they help us understand ourselves and they help us understand how we relate to
God in every experience,
even in grave danger and terrible difficulty. So,
uh, in Psalms 56, if you wanna turn there in verse one,
most of you have in your translation what's called
a superscript or a title. And uh, this is a very reliable,
uh, recent scholar.
Scholarly evidence suggests that these titles were connected to the text and
essential for understanding it puts these psalms in a specific context.
And so we have to look at it very closely. It says,
according to the dove of the far off terebinth.
Now nobody knows what that means, but it probably means that it was to be sung.
This psalm was to be sung to another tune called the Dove of the Far
Offterin. Now, we've all done that when I was a youth minister,
we used to sing amazing grace to different tunes just to get the kids singing.
Uh, I'll sing it and you tell me what it's from. Okay? Uh, amazing grace,
how sweet the sound that saved a res like me, that's house the Rising Sun.
For those of you under the age of 40, I'm sorry,
all my illustrations come from the seventies. Some of you'll get it,
some of you won't. Here's another one,
amazing Grace House Sweet of sound that saved a rats like me. Yeah,
Gilligans Island. Let's hear it for Gilligan. Now,
please don't clap on that one. Okay, well that's what this is a song,
song to a different song.
But the next couple of phrases are very critical for us. And that is this,
that, uh, this is a Mi of David or a MIT of David.
What that means is, is that we don't really know what that means.
We do know that in the Hebrew it means poem, but it's probably a musical term.
And we know that the next four Psalms, 56, 57, 58, 59, 60,
these are going to be mitts,
which means that this is us responding to God in the middle of a grave danger.
And so this is the first truth that you can write in your notes that in the face
of grave danger, God's people need to know He has not abandoned them,
nor has he abandoned his mission in the world.
So God is with you even when you don't feel like it.
And he has not abandoned you in the middle of difficult circumstances. In fact,
he's gonna provide for you hope and assurance for whatever danger or difficulty
come and he will accomplish his mission in the world.
And you can be certain of that. So the Supers subscriptions here says this,
and this is perhaps the most important piece of contextual, uh,
information when the Philistines seized him in goth.
Now we're gentiles. We don't know where Philis the Philistines lived.
We don't know where goth is. We certainly don't know who king ish is,
but David did.
And so keep your finger in Psalms 36 and then turn back for Samuel
21.
I'm gonna read to you five verses they're gonna establish the context of when
this psalm was written and what were the circumstance of grave danger.
And it says in David Rose and fled that day from Saul and went to King that
Aish, the king of goth. And the servants of Aish said to him,
is this not David the king of the land? Do they not sing to one another of him?
In in dances,
Saul has struck down his thousands and David his 10 thousands.
And David took these words to heart and was very much afraid of Aish,
the king of guy.
So he changed his behavior before them and pretended to be insane
in their hands and made marks on the doors of the gate and let spit run
down his beard. Then Aish said to his servants, behold,
you see the man is mad. Why then, have you brought him to me?
Do I lack of mad men?
Have you brought this fellow to behave as a madman in my presence?
Shall this fallow fellow come into my house? Well,
Psalms 56 reminds me of a prayer method that many of you're familiar with.
And if you're not, you need to be. It's called palms up, palms down.
And some of you know about this, but it's a prayer method that goes back a very,
very long time. In fact, nobody knows really where it started.
The earliest rec recorded use of this prayer method is by Ignatius
in, uh, a program he called examine. But, uh, in this prayer method,
you were encouraged to kind of hold your hands in your labs.
As you sit and palms up is you receiving
God's grace, his forgiveness,
you receiving God's mercy and his forgiveness and blessings and
palms down is when you are surrendering, you surrender your fears,
your anxieties, your worries, your distractions, your rebellion.
And that's what this, this psalm reminds me of the palms up, palms down method.
Because at the very beginning in the first two verses,
David May be at the lowest point in his life, he's lost almost everything.
His best friend Jonathan, his wife McCall, he's lost his family,
his reputation, his honor, his position in the, in Sal's kingdom.
He's lost everything,
but he's been promised by God and been anointed to be Israel's next
king by Samuel. So Israel's first king was Saul,
and he's growing increasingly jealous of David. In fact,
he's tried to commit murder against David four times now that we know of.
In fact, Bible says David was good looking,
which I don't know why it has to include that.
It says he had good looking eyes and he was ready in appearance and yeah,
whatever. And I could, I'm beginning to feel a little like Saul here, right?
He had miraculously killed the Philistine monster Goliath. I mean,
for goodness sake, one swing, one stone, one kill.
And so Saul is,
is increasingly jealous and he tries to murder David.
And so out of options and engrave danger,
he runs away to Israel's enemy, the Philistines.
And now in the hands of Israel's enemy,
he thinks faking insanity is his best option.
I never spit on myself, but I've done some stupid things over the years and,
and I don't see any hands, but I know there should be a few, right?
Today as we learn, even at his lowest point in life,
David hasn't lost everything. In fact, he has all he needs.
David has God's word and David has God's promise from Samuel. So we read,
first of all, palms down of David's terror.
Psalm 56, 1 and two says, be gracious to me. Oh God,
for man tramples on me all day long. And an attacker oppresses me.
My enemies trample on me all day long for many attack me
proudly. So Davis Re is releasing this terror.
This is an urgent appeal for God's help. He's crushed, he's flattened,
he's run over, he's stepped on, he's stomped on.
He is aish doormat.
He's being trampled and attacked all day long. Uh,
we've heard Bible scholars teach us that if something is repeated,
it needs to be reminded. And in these two verses,
it's repeated twice and once more after this all day long,
all day long, he's literally in between a rock and a hard place.
Rock being king's, Saul in God's armies and the hard place being king,
aka God in his armies.
And what we need to learn here is not a very fun thing to learn.
And that is this, that when we are in great need,
we will even run to danger to find relief.
The Philistines, these are Goliaths people.
They had hatred and anger against David when they sing.
David killed his 10 thousands. Those are 10,000 Philistine casualties.
He was hard pressed on every side.
And in his exhaustion then David's fear turns to God, David's trust.
We go from terror to trust. And these are palms off.
Now we know that a palms up.
We know that trust means that I have a firm belief in the reality and
the truth into the strength of God. I know that God is with me.
I know that God can do this. And this is what he says in verse three.
When I am afraid, I put my trust in you.
In God whose word I praise in God,
I trust and I will not be afraid for what can flesh do to
me? David being attacked on all sides. He knows God's promises.
And while he is still running,
he admits his crippling anxiety when I am afraid.
And if you've never been afraid, you are in denial. In fact,
I've heard recently from very scholarly resources that much of
American culture is afraid.
Many things are happening that are outside of our control. Geopolitically,
economically, physiologically,
I'm laughing cuz I'm getting old and I'm t I'm tired and sore and I don't know
why. You know, used to, like I say,
that's cuz that's what I did and that made me sore. Now it's just sore, right?
But there are so many things that are outside of our control that make us
afraid. And fact, our, our kids are turning away from church,
they're falling out of church and we don't know why and we can't seem to talk
them into coming back.
And so they need to see in us that because not not anxiety and
not fear, not distrust. They need to see,
trust David in the depths of anx, uh, his anxiety,
he assures God how much he trusts him.
He repeats it twice when he is afraid he will look to God and as a result,
then he'll not be as afraid. And because of this, he has full confidence of God.
God, you are faithful, you're reliable, you're loving, you're able,
you're strong. In the midst of this terror,
God has rock solid trust in God and his character and in God's
promises, David was confident that was,
that God was greater than all of his fears and that God would indeed help him.
Why then should he be afraid?
Are not all of his enemies merely flesh,
but God is God faithful and reliable and able and strong and
he can be trusted and be praised for his promises.
And so here are two things that you can count on for the rest of your life.
Humanity is powerless to prevent God's eternal purposes in life.
And number two, and this one's very um, this one's very meaningful to me
In the final analysis,
Jesus is Lord and God's purposes win. Uh,
young lady sitting out here and I were married 43 years as of last Wednesday
and we were dating right before I went into the ministry and she wasn't sure she
wanted be a minister's wife. She's still on the bubble about it actually.
But no, actually she's been a great resource to me.
But early on in our ministry we decided that we would fall back
after anything, after any um, glory,
after any praise, after any trial, after any trouble,
after any terror. And there's a lot of that in ministry,
on and on that we would say in the final analysis, Jesus' Lord,
I'm still going to heaven. And God's purpose is when Amen. Well,
David is saying, God, if you're God, what can any mortal man do to me?
There's nothing any mortal man can do except what God in his perfect sovereignty
permits.
And David has figured out that humanity is powerless to prevent God's eternal
purpose from going forward.
Yet this is another palm's down moment. David's trauma.
He says in verse five and six, he's an, he's a fugitive.
He's a refugee flinging for his life. Everybody is suspicious of him.
They're twisting his words. They don't trust him.
They have zero confidence in him. They don't want him around. In fact,
there's recommending to the king that he be dead.
Look what he says All day long they injure my cause.
All their thoughts are against me for evil. They stir up strife,
they lurk, they watch my steps.
They have waited for my life all day long.
They distract David from God's purpose. And then he says they injure my cause.
I think this is David taking God's purs purpose personally.
Do you do that? Do you take God's purpose in your life personally?
Do you see temptation and sin as a way of harming God's purpose in your
life? Because evil harms God's calling.
That's evil thoughts and evil words and evil relationships.
Those are a threat to God's calling all day long.
They're plotting to harm me all day long.
Evil men are twisting my words all day long. They lurk in the shadows, needing,
needing to take me down all day long.
They're watching my every step waiting for me to stumble all day long.
They're eager to pounce and take my life. Folks, this isn't paranoia,
this isn't dilution.
David's trauma is real and painful and potentially devastating.
But then there's David's triumph. This is palms up in verses seven, eight,
and nine for their crime.
Will they escape in wrath? Cast down the people's. Oh God,
you have kept count of my tossings.
Now that's not a word that we use very often. I looked it up in the Hebrew.
It can mean wonderings. Some of your translations may say wonderings,
but tossings means wonderings or miseries or sorrows.
You put my tears in a bottle. Are they not in your book?
Then my enemies will turn back in the day when I call this,
I know that God is for me. I just,
I don't know why I, this is a threat and you guys can make me look silly here,
but I just wanna try this. Okay, I'm gonna say this.
I know and you're gonna say that God is for me.
Don't say it like you don't mean it unless you don't.
You just sit there and let the conviction of the Holy Spirit take you down.
I'll do it with you the first time this I know that God is for me.
This, I know that God is for me. One more time.
This I know that God is for me.
We should be able to remember that we should let that,
that personalization of God's calling,
let let that be an attack against evil because we don't want to see that happen.
Because what David is pointing out here is first of all God's justice.
David plead him, pleaded, don't let them escape your divine justice.
He knows that these men are accountable to God.
He knows that their deeds are evil. He also knows God's view of sin. He is holy,
holy, holy. And his sin must be punished.
So if they're guilty of crime and cruelty,
then God will bring them down in guilty judgment.
But it's not all about God's justice, it's also about God's empathy.
David plainly states, this moves me,
that God makes record of our sorrows.
Saves your tears in a bottle.
God sees a David sees God's empathy wherever tear he shed in
the desert. List my tears in a book.
You know me and you care about me.
David knew that God cared enough to record his tears.
But then the ultimate triumph, it's this, I know that God is for me.
And this phrase reminds me of my favorite New Testament passage. In fact,
I can go back to 1982. Sorry, I know he is blo if you weren't born then, but uh,
I was uh,
a youth minister at this new church and they let me preach on a Wednesday night
cuz that's where we start the new guys. And so, uh,
I was preaching from this passage and I can remember reading this passage and I
can remember it overcoming me as I was reading it. And I can remember thinking,
this is what I want to pledge my life to. Romans 8 31,
what shall we say then in response to this? If God is for us,
who can be against us, who did not spare his own son,
but gave him up for us all,
how will he not also with him graciously give us all things?
Who shall bring charge against God's elect?
It is God who justify who is it to condemn Christ?
Jesus is the one who died more than that, who is raised,
who is at the right hand of God, who indeed is interceding for us.
Who shall separate us from the levo Christ shall tribu tribulation or distress
or persecution or famine or nakedness or danger or sword as it is written
for you are being killed all day long.
We are re regarded as sheep to be slaughtered. No,
no. In all these things, we are more than conquerors through him who loved us.
For I am sure that neither death nor life nor angels or rulers or anything
present or things to come nor powers nor height, nor death,
nor anything else in all creation will be able to separate us from the love of
God, which is in Christ Jesus our Lord. Amen. Amen. Amen.
That's David's triumph. And this is David's thankfulness.
This psalm concludes with a,
a great psalm sung about his thankfulness. So this is palms up.
Remember, a refugee in enemy territory,
probably with saliva still wet in his beard,
speaks as if God has already answered his prayers.
He finishes so strong with this declaration of praise in Thanksgiving,
God in his promises can be trusted. Look at verse 10,
in God whose word I praise in the Lord whose word
I praise in God, I trust I shall not be afraid. For what can man do to me?
I must perform my vows to you. Oh God, I will render thankful offerings to you.
For you have delivered my soul from death. Yes,
my feet from falling that I may walk before God In the light of life,
David has prayed himself to a place of confidence by faith in
God's promises who cannot lie.
David places himself in a space of confidence.
His confidence is in God and in God's word.
And even though his deliverance is still in the future,
he's certain about it right now.
David knew that God would give him a throne in the very land
that he has exiled from. And if God is God, he cannot break his promises.
And he promised that during the worst terror and trauma
of David's life, he knows God won't break his promises.
He know that no man can undo God's promise and he knows that he can give thanks
for his future deliverance right now he's confidence that God is gonna deliver
him in the future. God is God.
He always keeps his promises and his design purposes
cannot be defeated.
Jesus is God's promised deliverer who triumphed over Satan through his death
barrel and resurrection. He is that offspring of the woman he restored,
humanity's broken relationship with God. Jesus is the good news.
This is the gospel. Do you know him?
Look at this verse chapter 56,
because Jesus is like David in Psalms 56.
He also lived as an exile under the jealous leadership of Jewish leaders.
They hated him. They slandered him, they pursued him.
And eventually they had him killed. Like David. Jesus was promised a throne,
but this throne would be at the right hand of God like David,
Jesus entrusts his tears and sufferings into God's hands like David.
Jesus entrusts his justice to bring deliverance and
because God is God and his promises are sure God turned Jesus suffering into
resurrection, victory. Do you know him?
But listen to this, we are also like David and Psalm 56,
we too are exiled and alone and slandered and victimized in terror
and trauma.
We too are caught in between a rock and a hard place in between terror and
trauma and difficulty in danger.
We too have enemies that want to distract us from God's purpose.
We've gotta take that personally because they want to harm our calling,
our leadership as parents, our leadership as spouses,
our leadership in the church as we serve. But Jesus
is God's promise to us. And God always keeps his promises.
And because of Jesus,
God's perfect justice will be done on our behalf and God's promises will reign
with him forever. So I ask you,
I ask you if God is for us,
what can mere flesh do to us?
Because if Jesus' perfect sacrifice on the cross,
no condemnation or charge will come against us. Sin,
no sin is too big that it cannot be forgiven except the rejection of Jesus.
No enemy is too wicked that it cannot be brought to justice. Let me ask you,
do you know him? Let's pray.
Father of these last few moments, I would pray, Lord God, that you would uh,
direct our hearts through the power of the Holy Spirit to come to you.
That we would pray ourselves to a place of confidence
that we would know Father, that you are God and you are in perfect control.
And it's in Jesus. Now my prays,
please just keep your heads bow for just a minute. And I'm,
and if you're not comfortable with this, then I,
I don't want you to do to do this, but, but you,
you might just try for a moment, this palms up and palms down method of prayer.
And we're gonna start with our palms down. So with your hands in your lap,
put them down. Now remember,
this is you surrendering your worries and your fears and your anxieties and
your distraction, any rebellion you have to God.
Now it's time to let go of these things.
So I just welcome you to pray silently and I'll just direct your thoughts.
Do you wanna be free from crippling fear?
Do you feel crushed or run over or stepped on or stomped on?
In honesty,
can you express in prayer right now how you're feeling trampled and attacked?
How you're feeling fearful and anxious with your palms down?
Admit that to God And just give it away. Let it go.
Can you be as honest with God as David was about your weaknesses?
Have you been running the danger to find relief,
hidden behaviors, toxic relationships,
addiction? Just ask for forgiveness right now.
Verse John one, nine says, if we confess our sins,
he is faithful and Justin will forgive us of our sins and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness.
Tomorrow night we have celebrate recovery that meets us across the street or
just down the hallway.
And there they will meet you and they will agree with you that God is a God of
victory and they will walk with you through coming, overcoming that dependence.
Are you in a difficult conflict with someone and you don't know what to do and
people are twisting your words, waiting for you to fall? It's time to let,
let go of that bitterness.
Let your anger and your disappointment and your frustration let it go.
Are you experiencing suffering or sorrow? Surrender your fears.
Let that anxiety go. Your trauma is real and your pain can be devastating.
So just let loose of it right now. Give it to God.
Now If you don't mind,
just take a big deep breath and turn your hands over. It's time to receive,
to receive God's grace, to receive his forgiveness, his mercy, his blessings.
It's time to declare that God is God and he is faithful and reliable and able
and strong. And that nothing separates you from the love of Christ,
that you are more than conquerors through him who loved you.
Proclaim with certainty that God will accomplish his mission in the world and he
will use you as a faithful servant.
Praise him that he can be trusted because he keeps his promises and that he has
not abandoned you.
Praise God because Jesus' perfect justice will be done on your behalf.
Express
How thankful you are that God turned Jesus suffering into resurrection.
Vic victory.
No charge against you will stand no condemnation for those in Christ Jesus.
No sin too big that cannot be forgiven. Do you know him?
Just rejoice in God's deliverance.
At the end of the service there will be people on the sides.
And if you sense God is working in your heart right now,
that's the Holy Spirit saying you need to get this right and now is your
opportunity. They would be willing to pray with you, to hear your story,
to direct you to the right counsel. Father God,
thank you so much
For
Being you,
for taking on all my sins and my sorrows for remembering that I struggle.
But then Lord,
restoring me to a place where I could be used of you and called of you to
proclaim your gospel. Thank you that that's the story for all of us, Lord.
It's
In Jesus and we pray. Amen. Let's stand together.